-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy Award-winning actress
who you know from "Ratched,"
the "American Horror Story"
franchise,
and "The People vs.
O.J. Simpson."
She is both executive producing
and starring as Linda Tripp
in "Impeachment:
American Crime Story,"
which airs Tuesdays on FX.
Let's take a look.
-Can you at least tell me
did something happen?
-I told you
I have to talk to Kathleen.
-But will you call me
after you do?
Here's my card.
You can reach me --
-I know how to reach you.
-Okay. Alright.
-There's a bigger story.
Much bigger than this.
You're barking up
the wrong tree.
-Please welcome back
to the show and studio
Sarah Paulson, everybody.
♪♪
[ Light applause ]
-[ Laughing ] I like
the world's tiniest applause.
-No, it's not tiny.
-It's like clappity-clap-clap.
-No, they're good.
-Clap, clap, clap.
-They have big,
strong crew hands.
-Clap, clap. I like it.
So we don't have to pretend
there is an audience, right?
We can call it like it is.
-You can call it like it is.
-Or do people at home think
there's an audience?
-Well, that's the thing, is
sometimes people will be like,
"God, it was really quiet
last night."
I'm like,
"No, there's no one here."
-"She is tanking."
Unsuccessful.
-So that's good.
I think that's very good.
Especially as you're
the first guest of the night.
It's sort of incumbent on you
to establish
there's not an audience.
-Great, no pressure of any kind.
Great. Fantastic.
-It's so lovely to see you.
-It's lovely to see you
sans jacket.
-Sans jacket, and you sans
your Linda Tripp outfit.
That is a real transfor--
Though I guess your life
with Ryan Murphy
has been just, like,
transformation
after transformation.
-Yeah, I sort of feel like where
do you go after having two heads
and playing a heroin addict with
an electrocuted head of hair,
Chia Pet thing,
Chia Pet Marcia Clark wig.
I think Linda Tripp feels like
a natural progression to me.
I don't really know
where you go.
-There must be a fair amount of
discussion, though,
as far as, like,
how do you even go about
the costuming
for something like that.
The great thing about it,
I will say, is, like,
when it starts and you're
watching it, you're like,
"That's Sarah?" And then you
forget that's Sarah,
which is, I guess, the whole
point of, like, doing acting,
is making you forget
who the actual actor is.
-Yeah, I think a lot of times
people only want to play things
that are close to home, but I'm
like, "I want to be a pirate."
I want a peg leg
and a black tooth.
If I'm not having that,
then I'm not really --
-I guess a Ryan Murphy role
really takes care of --
Wait, is there your new --
Hold on. I want to make sure
I get the photo right.
This is your newest, right?
-This is Tuberculosis Karen.
-Tuberculosis Karen.
-Now, when Ryan calls and goes,
"I've got a great part for you,"
I mean, he knows you're gonna
jump at the chance to play --
-He does, because I'm a glutton
for punishment.
-Yeah.
-Yes.
-And let me just say.
I mean, this is no makeup,
right?
-This is me on your average
Monday morning, guys.
[ Laughter ]
This is sort of how I wake up.
Good morning, everybody!
Morning!
-I got to give the set
photographer credit
because they really grabbed
a perfect expression
for Tuberculosis Karen.
-They sure did.
Look at my sad eyebrows.
So, see, as Linda,
I had to erase them
because her eyebrows are
different than mine.
-Right.
-And so one of the ways
we figured out how we could
transform my face
was to bleach them.
But when you bleach them
and shave them,
you have to walk around
without them all of the time.
-Yeah.
-All of the time.
Not drunk at all, totally sober.
And so Ryan came up with
the idea to sort of do this
Warholian -- Warhalian?
-No, Warholian.
-Warholian.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Eyebrow above
the painted-out bleach.
And so it was
all a solve to hide Linda.
-For people who are watching
when this airs,
Tuberculosis Karen actually
has two sets of eyebrows.
-She has two sets of eyebrows --
the bleached ones
and then the bigger eyebrow.
-So everybody sees her and they
think things aren't going well
for Tuberculosis Karen.
Joke's on you.
She's got two sets. Things
are going so well for her.
-Yeah, exactly.
-She's got doubles.
-You have a dog, Winnie.
-I do have a dog, Winnie,
that I got
in the beginning
of the pandemic.
-People know about Winnie.
-You have shared Winnie
with the world.
-Winnie has been shared.
-We're going to break some news.
-Let's break the Internet.
-You got a second dog.
-Kim Kardashian
got nothing on us.
Okay, come on.
-You got a second dog.
-I got a second dog.
-What's the new dog's name?
-Her name is Louise,
but I call her Weezy.
-Weezy. Great. As you should.
So you got Weezy and Winnie.
-Weezy and Winnie.
-Okay.
-And how are they doing?
-It seemed okay
in the beginning,
but then there have been
a couple of tense moments
where they were -- let's just
say teeth I didn't know
my dog had were on display.
-So this is a photo of them
and I guess
someone made the argument
that they're playing.
-Sure.
-But this is...
One of these dogs does not look
like they're having fun.
Look at that.
[ Laughter ]
-But also, hello.
She looks like she's flying.
-Yeah.
-But this one also,
the dog is like, "Duh!"
[ Laughter ]
And Winnie is like,
"I said back, my lady!"
I just love it.
-It's true.
It is like this one is like, "I
think the date is going good."
-"I think she really likes me."
-"Yeah, I think it's good."
-"She really likes me."
[ Laughter ]
-So are they, in general,
would you say it's working?
-I think it's happening. The
very thing that I wanted to do
was to prevent my dog from --
I anthropomorphize the dog,
so if she looks out the window,
I think she's looking longingly
for her Prince or Princess
Charming and it's not coming.
So I brought the dog home
to try to --
And then as you can see,
it's going swimmingly.
-Something else that's going --
I want to give you a shout-out
because you were mentioned
last week on the show.
Amanda Peet has a wonderful show
called "The Chair."
And she basically
gave you credit
for being casting director.
-Yes.
-You connected her with
Sandra Oh, who's a friend.
You probably had the number
in your phone.
-Yes, e-mail.
-But then Holland Taylor,
who was a lot easier
for you to contact.
-Yeah, I just basically
went in the other room
and said, "Hey, Dumb-Dumb,
please do the show
and don't be crazy
and also don't make me look bad
to my best friend."
-Not that I think
Holland could ever make you
look bad as an actor.
-Never.
-But in social situations,
I'm sure she embarrasses you
all the time.
-She's embarrassing me
constantly!
-But as an actor, not once.
-Never.
-But she's so good in it.
-She's so good in it.
-Yeah.
-Funny. I mean, but, you know,
Holland is that funny
all the time.
I took a video of her in
the hotel room the other night.
Not creepy. It's not a creepy
video, guys, super not creepy.
But of her singing a song called
"It's Choco Coffee Time"
set to like "Howdy Doody Time"
because she drinks a cup of
coffee in the morning
that is a vat of hot chocolate
and international coffee creamer
and then, like,
a tiny drop of espresso,
and she needs her -- so she's
like, ♪ It's choco coffee time ♪
♪ It's choco ♪
And she started doing a dance,
and I just --
I recorded it,
and if you are really lucky,
you'd get that video
before I leave.
-Well, I certainly hope one day
I'll get it.
-She's gonna kill me
for telling that story
because she was spinning around
in her little pajamas.
♪ Choco coffee ♪
-Well, when you drink that much
hot chocolate,
you're gonna spin around.
It's got to go somewhere.
-It was really something.